although he's best remembered for his
contributions to sci-fi television as
creator of Star Trek many of Gene
Roddenberry's show concepts never got
off the ground after his death in 1991
his widow Majel Barrett discovered a
stash of Roddenberry scripts and notes
for some of these proposed shows one of
which became sci-fi channels hit series
Andromeda with over 100 episodes
wrapping up over a decade ago in 2005
here's what the stars of Andromeda are
up to today Kevin Sorbo as one of the
elite high guard of the system's
Commonwealth Kevin Sorbo is captain
Dylan hunt in his starship Andromeda
sinden were responsible for protecting
the planets and inhabitants of three
galaxies until his leap 300 years into
the future after the series ended Sorbo
who was previously best known for
playing Hercules continued building upon
his prolific acting career with
appearances in the OSI meet the Spartans
and many other films and TV shows
additionally Sorbo lent his voice to
several videogame characters in titles
like Skylanders superchargers and has
reprised his role as Hercules in the God
of War game franchise most recently you
can spot Sorbo and Supergirl
lissa writer Lisa Ryder's Becca
Valentine had never been interested in
saving the galaxy until she crossed
paths with Captain Dylan hunt and she
became a loyal member and first officer
of the Andromeda crew these days the
canadian-born Rider is still working as
an actress she's appeared in over a
dozen different roles in TV and film
most recently nurse Greenwood in the FX
horror series the strain additionally
Reiter has returned to theatre where she
got her start her play while dachshund
was featured in a workshop reading
during the 2017 groundswell festival in
Toronto
Laura Bertram at the start of the series
the purple skinned humanoid alien trance
Jim and I played by Canadian actress
Laura Bertram at a bubbly and effusive
personality only later transforming to
reveal her true nature since the end of
the series Bertram has enjoyed a
successful acting career you may have
spotted her in guest roles on the
popular shows supernatural and Once Upon
a Time or in her recurring role on the
hallmark channel's when calls the heart
additionally Bertram is a high school
teacher in British Columbia as well as
an instructor at biz studio screen
acting school in Vancouver
Gordon Michael Wolfe it after the fall
of the Commonwealth Boston born Seamus
Harper played by Gordon Michael Wolfe
escaped from the Nietzschean x' and
eventually ended up as a crewman for
valentine wolf it has since appeared on
supernatural the Canadian drama the
guard in the CW horror series iZombie
wool vid is also comfortable behind the
camera as a director as evidenced by his
2017 documentary around the world in 80
anthems LexA Doig known affectionately
by the crew is Rami the Android avatar
of the powerful artificial intelligence
within the ship Andromeda ascendant was
portrayed by Toronto native Alexandre
doy following her stint on Andromeda
Doig has continued to work on several
sci-fi TV shows including supernatural
Stargate sg-1 V and continuum fans may
remember her from the 2002 horror film
Jason X most recently Doig appeared on
arrow as well as the arrangement chief
hamilton cobb among the andromeda crew
ruthless nietzsche and mercenary keith
hamilton Cobbs tear Anasazi was a
fascinatingly complicated character to
pin down Cobb left the series after the
fourth season and immediately
transitioned into his role as Damon
Porter on The Young and the Restless
Cobb then moved on to logos Noah's Ark
and CSI Miami in recent years Cobb has
returned to the theatre pinned a number
of short stories and other written works
and is currently touring his one-man
show American Moore Steve basic
Nietzschean weapons officer Telemachus
rod a played by Steve basic was a late
comer to the Andromeda crew having
joined captain Dillon hunt in season two
following his spot on the series basic
continued in his career with hallmarks
all for love blade the series the guard
and HBO's Big Love most recently he
reunited with LexA Doig in an episode of
arrow brandy Ledford the Android Doyle
played by brandy Ledford debuted on the
show when she was built by Seamus Harper
while he was stranded with a
malfunctioning Rami after the series
former model Ledford appeared on
Canadian mystery drama Whistler Stargate
Atlantis Modern Family and NCIS Los
Angeles thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]